this is the one and only liam gallagher
and i'm going to be finding out what the
lad bible think of me
all right who is liam's dream dinner
party guest for me i reckon keith moon
would be a good one who do you think the
audience have said oh they'll probably
say john no they won't have someone else
or no or someone
stupid like that
oh guardian guardiola oh yeah yeah man i
didn't think of that it didn't pop it in
my head do you know what i mean pep
guardiola footballers and all that a bit
dare to say it you know i mean
squared aren't they you know what i mean
unless they've won the league they've
got to behave themselves out they'll be
getting off at about nine o'clock to go
but
the queen no not a fan
i don't i don't mind her because she's
an old bird and all that and i like her
i guess at all it's reminds me grandma
my mom and all that but
you know she'd end up getting your head
chopped off wouldn't she for swearing
this stuff
john lennon i said keith moon oh didn't
i yeah
john lennon as well
but nobody man i'm happy with that one
person did actually say sir alex
ferguson right well
yeah listen
listen at the end of the day ferguson's
top manager and i mean i'd like to go
with him this weekend out and [ __ ]
rub it in his face but at the end of the
day they've won loans and he's so i'm
sure he'd have us back
what real reality tv show would you most
like to see liam in right it's got a bit
of jungle on it gotta be they'd love to
see me in that squirming eating [ __ ]
frogs [ __ ] balls and [ __ ]
you know what i mean
right here we go
love ours
love island i ain't got the body for it
when i bring sexy back whenever i get my
[ __ ] together and i'll be in there but
me and me misses watch a bit of that
sometimes but
for kids in it you know what i mean
really
great british bake off not into that
[ __ ] that's a problem with this
[ __ ] country right here right now too
many [ __ ] programs on food man and
then there's nothing on music you know i
mean the only one that you've got he's a
jewels holland you got those dicks
baking [ __ ] cakes and [ __ ] bread
and all that
[ __ ] off are you the fan of baking no no
no no i'm a fan of music much rather
music shows than [ __ ] baking silly
baking programs okay
i'm not having that i'm just celebrity
get me out of here any day yeah
but no no i'm a [ __ ] bag when it comes
to spiders and stuff like that man nah
not a chance not all not they don't have
the money then i've got a budget to get
me in there yeah it's about to say how
much
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do it i'd
rather just just walk the streets and
beg you know what i mean if i needed the
money you're not you know i mean i
wouldn't do it no i'm not interested
creepy crawlies in that so what would
you if you had to do one i'd probably do
the celebrity one you know what i mean i
guess so they're right because i'm not
doing the [ __ ] i'm not entertaining this
bake off nonsense
i love ireland it's [ __ ] pretty boys
in it
lives with six packs and [ __ ]
no you're getting all guinness there man
right what question do you think liam is
the most tired of being asked top three
answers one when when's oasis getting
back together how's your brother know
all that nonsense when are you gonna
have a fight with robbie williams
by the way she's pretty cool
we all know that the little fella
got into a sulk anything about an old
day ago
number one his oasis getting back
together see
i don't mind getting asked about that
because it's natural you know what i
mean i like talking about oasis because
it's the best band in the world so um
it's wrong again man
are you
well getting back together not this week
but i mean i'm ready to go my bags are
packed
maybe a week after
there was in another band which these
would be in
a
one direction come on
b blur leave it
see attic monkeys d queen e
the bit the beatles
that's it man what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] pirates the beatles believe it
or
not
do you think liam would make a good
prime minister without doubt but too
good looking for it it's for ugly hey
yes
be no
i've oh [ __ ]
now they're right i wouldn't because i'm
too good looking for that stuff but
anyone to do a better job than the dude
that's in there now so i think they're
wrong man what be your first policy what
would you i'd [ __ ] have to just put a
lawyer in and just gaffer tapes scousers
mouths
just like and then i i've also write
champions across what would you do
carragher
definitely in i know where else would
they be and then man united fans
followed quickly second than that i'm
not getting political on that but voting
for governments just i would if i was
prime minister i'd ban all governments
and just let and just let people use the
common [ __ ] sense you know what i
mean they don't need governments telling
us what to do
who would liam like to see as the next
james bond
actually that's who i want him out so i
think yeah man i think he'd be mega he's
got a beautiful face and he's good
looking
great actor he's sober i'm not sure
about that
number one himself
i mean i'd be good at the booze in
the martini i know that i'm [ __ ]
being a smart ass and all that sucker
but you know i would be good at it
actually if i lost a bit of [ __ ]
weight get a suit on i'd be [ __ ]
banging yeah they're right
they clumped up this claw batman they're
coming back no i would be i'd be better
than [ __ ] aegis albert anyway
you have a little barbie once i did yeah
and i was like i don't even know where
it was everyone's going kidding daddy's
like no [ __ ] idiot messing me up and
then i went over
got this bubble out and booted it down
the [ __ ] and then it all got a bit
naughty and all that but
i think we've apologized since then and
all that tackle and it was just the
drunken thing and all that but here's
what it is don't [ __ ] mess with
people's airport and then we won't boot
your [ __ ] bubble like down the road
goddess now right which of these current
artists would lean most likes to listen
to
ali styles
kanye west no chance cardi b not sure
but i don't know what's more much about
her
there was capaldi
juve lipper
[Music]
sam fender for me some fender look
sounds like he's having a laugh at a
good time at the moment do you really
don't really know her luis capaldi seems
like he's a bit of a lad and has a laugh
cardi b
yeah i don't really know much about her
kanye west [ __ ] weirdo
harry styles
i like harry he'd be all right but
he's not he's a he's a clean living lady
you know what i mean so i think he's
doing all right and that's some addy
styles i'm going to go with yeah i am
actually
sam tender
yeah i mean because he plays guitar in
and he's up north and all that but and
he likes a lager i like sam fender which
are the top 10 selling away songs is
liam's favorite um it's going to be live
forever that's what i think they'll say
what's your favorite my favorite i think
it's the forever i mean i like them all
but
the forever is a bit sentiment you know
sentimental than that let's see right
i wonder what did he say
what's up with them i don't know
wonderful i mean it's all right and i
know it's not he's taking a piss that
used to do my head in that chair and
i've only started to come around to it
again but as i got older but ah come on
lad bible
who should play liam in a bio
of his life biopic of his
i don't really know any like really
decent actors like that cool like me you
know what i mean but um i'm not going to
go into the answers
do you know him
oh yeah yeah he used to be in emmerdale
didn't he yeah i'm having him two
something nah [ __ ] that song
i'm had he's [ __ ] he's about that big
and he's a stocky [ __ ] even though
he's a mega actor and all that but he's
not a [ __ ] good look i'm not saying
the other one's [ __ ] good-looking but
somehow he's short ass in it
himself i'd play myself but then i get
one of my kids to do it as well because
they look they look they look cool gosh
who does liam think he's the greatest
man city player of all time for me uh
obviously in the modern areas aguero
kevin de bruyne yaya toure silva mike
summer be from the past and that there's
loads and that but
now that he's within the modern days i
would go aguero
kevin de bruyne yeah mega
seriously oh okay
into the company ah i forgot about
venison but no i mean sergio aguero i
think for me how did you celebrate
winning the league all right so i wasn't
meant to be drinking because i've got
these gigs coming up but i just [ __ ]
got my head was stressed out man in the
morning so i didn't go with a match
because i don't go because i can't be
dealing with
squares telling me to behave or not so
uh stayed at home watched it gene come
round our kid come around
and it just it was horrible a horrible
day man until the very end i was just
sitting there in the chair going out
even when we went too too hard i was
going i ain't [ __ ] getting off this
chair to celebrate it's [ __ ]
ridiculous that we're two nil down or an
hour too old i'm not doing it even even
if we score when we scored the third
goal i wasn't bothered i was like when
that whistle blows then i'm partying
because you know what city you're like
they can
you can pause it up at any given minute
so uh
no i was i'm glad it's all done man
theme was an animal which would he beat
right i've said this before i reckon
everyone might go monkey and [ __ ] like
that but it's a dolphin
dog
monkey
sloth
lion no man
yeah there you go why do they say that
that's because i just [ __ ] probably
look like one don't i mean i'll [ __ ]
them out like a monkey and
just cheeky monkey
just to let you know that one person did
say naked attraction really yeah well
that's obviously my biggest fan
what is naked attraction
oh it's that show dirty
hi guys i am tom holland and today i'm
going to find out what the lab bible
audience thinks of me i'm very nervous